this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
tuesday the 26th of the month i'm
[__] excited we got ufc
277 make your big win this weekend with
draftking sportsbook the official
[__] sports betting partner of
the ufc listen we got football coming up
we're living in baseball but this sunday
saturday whatever the [__] we got the
ufc 277 you want even more action you
could also double your winnings on the
same game ballet this saturday new
customers listen you're gonna bet five
dollars in any fighter to win and i'm
gonna get you 103 bets win or lose
that's the beauty about ufc 277 we got
same game paulie so if you want to do
juliana pena and amanda nunez and go to
over and under which is probably like
three and a half rounds
you got it draftkings is safe
secure and reliable not only do we have
amanda nunes we got brandon moreno we
got derek lewis we got alex perez we got
anthony smith we got a tremendous card
this weekend and you can make some
[__] gears for real listen to me
draftkings are safe secure and reliable
you can withdraw your cash whatever they
want not only am i
i work for them but i'm also a
[__] player with them and let
me tell you they are phenomenal so do me
a favor download the draftking sports
back cap today right now use promo code
joey that fight is another ufc 277
fighter to win and i'm gonna get you 100
in free bets no matter what whether you
know ufc or not if you know ufc put your
[__] mouth your money behind your
[__] mouth [__] that's code
joey this saturday at draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the ufc
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply
now go make some [__] money
with draftkings
the joint is also brought to you by cbd
lion one of my personal favorites i'm a
user and i love it
you need cbd line in your life go to cbd
line right now read
the third party lab results you're not
gonna believe what the [__] you're gonna
read on here
i've been using a cbd line and i've
tried every one of their products from
the vapor pen
to the cbd gummies to the delta eight
gummies to the kinesiology tape they're
not messing around
if your shoulder hurts whatever you put
a little piece of tape on your shoulder
within minutes you'll be [__] working
out like you own the [__] gym so do
me a favor go to cbd lion
read the third party lab results if the
[__] kinesiology tape works for you
do me a favor
go put in code joey joint or church and
get 20 off your first order anyway you
should be going over there for the delta
8 gummies because i'm going to save you
20 off the [__] first order so go do
what you got to do
cbd lion pressing code joey and now
let's get this [__] party
started jack it's tuesday morning
welcome to uncle joey's joint
[Music]
boom what's happening you bad
[__] it's tuesday the 26th of
[__] july sorry we're coming at
you late we're gonna do it monday but it
was too [__] hot
i was down to shore i was having a good
time mike was having a [__] good time
so we said [__] it what's tuesday
instead of monday you know what i'm
saying it's a beautiful [__] week
it's a hot [__] day let me tell
you something guys it has been
brutal but in the [__] like guys look
if you're gonna go out and build the
house you're gonna [__] die it's
gonna be hot you know what i mean let's
be as honest as we can with each other
if you're gonna go out there and walk
around and [__] sit still and [__]
and you have a shade it's not bad
yesterday in my yard i was back there
smoking joints it was 102 people were
passing out i was back there smoking
joints at night and i'm like this is
[__] delicious but if i went to the
front of the house i would [__] melt
like a icicle you know so it's hot
be careful i mean saturday down the
shore
dog i had a great time but i will tell
you a part of the day you know i'm gonna
hold the gentleman whatever i'm gonna
hold the savage now
so
i mean i was a block not even guys i i
can't lie to you i was 30 yards away
my
towel or whatever the [__] chair i
don't know wherever i was sitting was 30
feet away from where you walked
out you know i got to the shore at 11.
i went in the water it was [__]
freezing but it felt tremendous because
it was so hot out but if you're sitting
on the beach you know it's just i was
sweating a little bit but after a while
you're drinking water you're hydrating
you know you're jumping in the water
every 30 minutes
when i put my feet in the [__] water
the first time i thought i was gonna
pass out it was so goddamn cold at 11
o'clock i can't lie to you guys i'm not
used to all that [__] that water was
[__] freezing but when i got up at
two o'clock it was a different story
guys i got up i had a chair you know
what a chair weighs two pounds
especially these chairs they give you
it's complimentary chairs at the hotel
to get me a chair and
all i was holding was my phone
and i got to tell you just that 30-foot
walk by the time i got i mean when i got
up guys my t-shirt was dry by the time i
got to the sidewalk i was drenched and i
had that fat juice coming out of here
like you have sweat and then you have
fat juice
that fat juice is really slippery sweat
just goes down and coats your face and
you wipe it off and at first the salt
comes out so it burns your eyes but the
second load is that sweat from your neck
that has like michigan juice and [__]
clam juice and fat juice and cell juice
that [__] was [__] thick
i only had a walk from and i'm telling
you this guys to straight up i only had
to walk
maybe another 30 feet and when i got in
that air conditioning
my t-shirt was drenched from the [__]
collar
all the way down i went to the hotel
i drank a [__] liquid iv i [__]
drank maybe
two bottles of water
and i relaxed upstairs and then when the
girls came back i went to the pool and i
felt 100 better but
it was [__] hot when i told a friend
of mine that he goes dog
it was blistering hot like people could
[__] die out there yesterday they
showed beaches
pictures of beaches and a lot of them
were empty
people were like [__] we're just going
to sit inside listen you can't sit
inside you got to go out there and get
the sun and the heat and i'm going to be
as long as i can with you
i went to lbi i hadn't been an lbi in 40
[__] years
when you were on the beach yeah you were
hot but then there was like a little dip
to the water like maybe a little dip to
the water they built it up oh my god
when you went down there and that water
hit your feet you were [__] cold i
mean it was like
the heat had been removed by like 15
degrees i never thought it was just a
wall
once you dropped into that ocean which
is maybe a three-foot drop they build it
up for the
whatever the the tide comes back guys it
was so [__] nice i just stood there
for like an hour at one point because
i'm like this is better than [__]
sitting there like a dunce
but
i hadn't been down this [__] listen
my pla i had a plan last year my plan
was
to go to all these shores i hadn't been
to but after i went to point pleasant i
had a bad taste in my mouth and i grew
up in point pleasant i always loved
point blanc
point pleasant is like a family [__]
beach you know
but when i went there last year it was
bumper to bumper people
i smelt [__] blunts
and weed from every [__] direction
you know and listen guys you know me i'm
a [__] savage i don't usually give a
[__] what you do
i don't give a [__] if you shoot heroin
in front of me i really don't i would
never say nothing to you i get it i'm
with you
but there's a time and a place i'm i
swear to god you know there's a time and
a place for everything i listen i'm not
here to [__] ruin your party you go
to new york city they got people over
there
they have street charges so people
charge their phones to go on youtube and
you porn and they're [__] whacking
off right in the [__] street you know
for a year during the pandemic new york
city police cannot arrest you if you're
shooting drugs on the street
san francisco has shooting galleries you
know where you go in and it's safer for
you and people fighting those things
again i don't want to get into this
right now guys i'm just trying to tell
you that
if you want to [__] do quaaludes
there's a show for you
if you want to get [__] gang raped
there's a show for you if you want to
[__] a bunch of people there's a show if
you want to get drunk there's a journey
but if you're a mike and you want to
bring your two kids down and you don't
want to hear [__] you
every three words there's family beaches
you know so you could pick whatever the
[__] you want so when i got back here
last year
my first impression was to go to point
pleasant
because it was
[__] great when i was growing up it
was a paradise they got jenkinson's they
got [__] it's just great and i got to
tell you i still like the show but it
was [__] packed with me on a weekend
so now when i go down to point pleasant
i just go during the week at night get
something to eat i go down i go to uncle
vinnie's uncle vinnie's is on point
pleasant they do other comedy down there
on tuesdays but i [__] with uncle
vinnie's you know i'm saying that's it
but uh yeah when you go to point
pleasant the last time i went it was
scattered and i got to tell you
something
there were people everywhere it was just
too much for uncle joey so i was like
i get it you know a lot has changed in
40 [__] years joey
everybody goes down the shore you know
it's like why you can't go to long
island on the weekend like i won't even
book a date out there i told linda i
would call her for a thursday night
which i am going to i want to go to long
island i miss it maybe do one of those
clubs out there but
you go to long island on friday and
saturday it's a four-hour drive
it's four hours for me to get to the
beach everybody in this area either goes
to long island now or the [__] jersey
shore
that's where they go i mean it is so
[__] congested down at the shores
so we were gonna go to cape may i've
been to cape may [__] beautiful you
know family beach i'll tell you what
you're gonna drop some loot
you go to cape may they ain't [__]
around
none of these places are [__] around
like
they're just not [__] around like you
go to point please and get a nice hotel
room you go to seaside again you go to
seaside you're going to hear [__] noises
in your room with your kids
people going to be [__] having orgies
and [__] pot room is going to be coming
into the events there's sand everywhere
you know so these but it's fun
this is what i told my wife i like last
week what happened was we have family
and they invited us down to tuckerton
right we go down there a lot it's just a
plain
[__] jane
short town they don't have a beach they
just have an inlet but people live there
to save three hundred thousand dollars
and they drive to lbi and just get the
[__] beach it's the same thing you
know so we were gonna go down to
tonkinton on friday
and then i saw it was gonna be burning
on i told my wife i go listen
it's gonna be a hot [__] weekend i
don't want to just go to the pool and
not see anybody [__] everything
let's just go down friday hang out with
them and get a [__] hotel on saturday
and stay till sunday that was the plan i
was gonna come back at 10 o'clock
someday we were going to come back
but then the tuckerton people who i love
to that the galas you know they were
like listen we're going to have a full
[__] house you could stay
friday night don't have to get a hotel
and just get a hotel saturday but we
went online my wife's like i can't get a
hotel
so i was like you know like i told you
[__] when you want to book a
flight or you want to get a hotel you
call uncle joey okay
i'll sift through it she gave up she
came down she's like i checked
you know lbi i checked monologue and i
checked surf city there's nothing down
there i go what hotel do you want to
stay at she goes hotel i'll be out
i go let's call
because all you [__] that
settle on a computer you're [__]
[__] okay
you go on there and you see the prices
and you do everything on the computer
[__] you i want my [__] facts right i
don't want no misunderstandings with
travelocity and none of that [__] you
book with travelocity try canceling try
getting your money back good [__]
luck
so all that [__] is just [__]
[__] so i just called the hotel and
you go listen man
we're looking for a room for the weekend
right away she goes we just had three
cancellations
they're not going to put them on the
computer guys
they're not going to put them in the
computer couple [__] a year ago when
i went to l.a to go to the dentist and i
doctor what happened i got locked out
remember every [__] website i went on
i couldn't get a flight out of la i
picked up the phone i called [__]
whatever that program i belonged to
jetblue and they're like oh what a
surprise
a ticket just opened up a ticket always
opens up [__] they're just not
going to give it to you on that [__]
computer they don't want you to take
[__] for granted so i called and when my
when i gave my wife the phone and i go
how much is it for two nights my wife
goes wow
she just put her hand on the phone she
goes wow joey they want a lot of money
terry what am i gonna do you want to sit
here
like a [__] dunce it's like we can't
take a [__] plane trip
my friend i had three people four people
taking a flight on [__] friday you
ready for this
two of their flights got canceled one
[__] got delayed like eight
hours and the other one jimmy florentine
was on time
like nothing happened she was like
nothing happened in fact we got here
early so you never know what the [__]
gonna happen but i'm not flying for that
reason that just hey everybody gets
lucky the week before he was he was
[__] held back for 16 hours so
you're always gonna have something so
i'm not going nowhere so i said what are
we gonna do we're just gonna sit here
all [__] summer i mean we're driving
the [__] north carolina
but that's in august to some [__] late
august or something like that and now my
wife telling me we might not even stay
in north carolina for the full week
she's like i don't think so
we're gonna [__] leave here drive
yeah go to delaware see my family
shoot down north carolina maybe on the
way back [__] stop up but
back to the [__] show i mean
so we got down there friday we had a
little barbecue at my friend's house he
made some sausage and peppers
i played with the kid we went crabbing
we put i saw a [__] i've never seen
this before in my life guys
and don't get me wrong i don't want to
say the bird because i might say the
bird wrong but you're sitting there i'm
sitting there i got [__] you know 300
i got like 700 milligrams of thc in me
oh i called [__] uh i called
stoners kitchen they got some good
[__] edibles guys if you're in jersey
and you want some nice [__] weed but
some [__] great edibles
those 350 milligram gummies they have
will put you on another planet they have
an almond bar like an almond joy with
almonds and coconut oh my god
and they got a [__] uh ice cream cake
a wedding cake oh lordy so
i had some medals with me the baby went
upstairs my wife went upstairs they're
talking about going over to check in i'm
just sitting there it's like 4 30.
beautiful [__] day i'm just looking
at lbi because from whatever anyway it
doesn't matter i see a [__] bird what
type of bird is i have no idea he's a
big guy like you know i don't know three
feet and he jumps on the [__] on the
dock
guys i've never seen this before i'm
sorry he [__] had something in his
mouth and he just [__] slammed it on
the floor was a crab
and they try to yeah they crack them
open i thought it was a gunshot i'm like
what is this bird doing with a [__]
i'm like what the [__] is going on he
just smashed it and then they smash it
they kill it or they break the shell and
they eat the meat out of it dog i was
[__] blown away i saw a couple things
down there another time i was just
sitting there we had the cages in there
and i guess one of the crap one of the
[__] crabs got out of the cat i don't
know something happened one of the crabs
didn't go in the cage he was walking on
top of the cage and i'm looking awesome
the bird is just flying around also this
[__] just crashed into the water
and took out this little [__] you
just see this little wing holding on i'm
like holy [__]
[__] shark week this is a lot better
than [__] shark week
i didn't see any sharks i didn't see
[__] but
we got to drop a story on here so
when i went to see [__] enter the
dragon with
with ari part of the deal was i was
going to go over there and bring him
some tremendous reefer but he was gonna
give me some shroomah
so he gave me a couple of shrooms so i
was just saving it for the right [__]
night
so friday night i figured you know
what am i doing down here i'm not doing
[__] you know what i'm saying i'm just
breathing
so before then i took the mushrooms with
me to dinner and every time i took a
bite of the [__] and roasted clams or
the [__]
whatever i was eating i don't even know
what i ate we had appetizers like clams
on a half shell and shrimp cocktail like
we split it six ways nobody was really
hungry
but i kept eating an appetizer and
popping a [__] mushroom cap
i would eat a [__] clam and pop one
of those [__] wings
i ended up popping like five of those
[__] things those stems stems and one
cap
and i'm like nothing's hitting me you
know so
i'm sitting there i'm having a good time
it's like [__] six people we're
giggling my daughter's there she's
torturing my friend
and all of a sudden the [__] waiter
comes up to me he's like hey man
can we take a picture with you or
whatever and he had like great people
great food great restaurant hotel rbi
but like he had like a hat
like he had like a little pompadour kind
of thing and when i was looking at him i
could see the pompadour
start to move and he's like can we take
a picture and i'm like oh
[__]
these [__] mushrooms are starting
already whoo
we took the picture and [__] and then
i started [__] laughing
uncontrollably like anybody who told me
a joke or something i couldn't [__]
contain myself i was like
i felt like a [__] [__] i kept
giggling and giggling and giggling
and then i went upstairs
and i'm like all right now it's gonna
get good so i waited for my daughter to
fall asleep i rolled the [__] nice
joint i put some teeth in that
[__] i smoked it
then nothing happened i got a little
stoned i laid down i peed like four
times and that was it what the [__]
mushrooms made me was itchy as [__]
but
i got the giggles and all that stuff i
just didn't get the [__] uh i didn't
get to see anything but don't don't
don't worry about argentina i got some
[__] saved up i'm gonna blast
them because i know listen i'm a big cup
of coffee you know what i'm saying so
like i've only been [__] up on
mushrooms one time and it was in
colorado it was many years ago but i got
a batch of [__] diarrhea so i never
really um i got three hits of acid that
my man sent me when he sent me this
shirt that i've been holding onto too
cuz but the acid that you do now gets
you high for three hours you get like
that strong
for two hours you'll get like a streak
or something it's not the [__] that used
to make me [__] see the devil you
know
but
i got a little high and i just passed
out it wasn't i i wanted to see the
devil you know me dog i'm always up for
seeing something
or hearing a new language something i
haven't listened to before
you know i'm always up for something but
nah
it didn't [__] work out saturday we
just went to the beach
and uh we went back you know i told you
i didn't feel good so i went back to the
pool and did my liquid iv
and then the moms came back like six
moms came back a bunch of [__] kids
and we just started ordering pizzas and
[__]
wings and all this [__] but let me tell
you something i told lee i called lee
right away and i go lee
cause lee likes this [__]
there was a pizza that we ordered a
spicy sausage pizza
they had i guess the you know it was
like little bar pizzas you know so they
ordered like a nona pizza a grandma
pizza
a cheese pizza and a spicy sicilian
i don't really want to i don't know i'm
kind of burnt out on pizza but the
the spicy sausage i go let me try it
dawg when i tasted that [__] pizza it
blew up in my mouth all right you bad
[__] and now for a word
from our sponsors listen
you have to take care of your mind we
spend a lot of time taking care of our
skin getting suntans but everybody
forgets about the brain
how well you take care of the brain
affects your experience
life and how you experience it investing
time and energy and mental health
is crucial to happiness so eating right
working out getting plenty of street
leap that's all great starts but there's
no substitute for talk therapy better
help makes online therapy accessible
convenient and affordable listen there's
no stigma about going to therapy anymore
guys
you know what we live rough lives
sometimes we need to talk to somebody
that's just not a friend that just makes
sense that just helps us with better
help
dana really helped me out a lot
just to let you know better help is
online therapy that offers video phone
and chat therapy sessions if you don't
want to talk to nobody if you don't want
to see anybody on video that's fine
they'll just talk to you on the chat
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist within 48 hours two days
listen you're not going to find a
face-to-face therapist now they're all
booked up and talking to people and
they're in deep
with better help i get your help in two
days
it works on a monthly but what i'm going
to do for you is this joint listeners
get 10 off first month at betterhelp.com
diaz again that's betterhelp.com
diaz
better help they're here to help and
they will help so go to betterhelp.com
press and code diaz d-i-a-z and i'm
gonna get you 10
off the first month now back to the
joint
it was the finest [__] pizza i've
ever tasted in my life ready for this
and you guys know i hate a lot of [__]
i'm gonna break it down for you they had
nice cheese
nice italian sausage spicy and they put
a little chorizo for flavor in that
[__] but here's the clinker they
put a white sauce on it with little
pieces of corn in it
at first i looked at and i'm like here
we go i'm in [__] whiteville with
this pizza with corn on it
dog i took a taste of it
i i thought my head was gonna [__]
blow up
it was
delicious i had like three slices
i called lee i go lee
because lee's coming august [__]
tenth
to spend the [__] week down here with
his girlfriend to go to the beach and
[__] so i go lee
you gotta stop over there and get a
[__] slice of that pizza i don't care
what they charge you they have like an
arugula pizza
all of them were pretty [__] good
but you think
do you really think you'd ever hear me
say a pizza with corn would be good i
never even thought i would [__] bite
into it but i just had an inkling about
it just looked different
[__] tremendous man and that was it
that was
we hung out with the moms and the kids
you know
it's funny because
i tell everybody my life is not about me
right now i
my entertainment is doing this going to
jiu jitsu and smoking a bong hit a
couple nights a week i get giggly i have
no entertain when i tell people this
they don't understand what i'm doing i'm
not dead i'm not dead yet i'm not saying
that i'm dead
but i'm saying that anything i wanted to
really [__] do
i did it already so right now my
my shot is over right now my life is in
the hands of the youth
i look at the [__] youth you know
when it comes to comedy i look at shane
gillis and i look at these young comics
but what i'm trying to point out is it's
not about me it's about my my daughter
it's about my daughter and her little
[__] friends
you know i already had my mic you know
we did it all let's say what do you want
us to do
we bring back led zeppelin what do you
want us to regroup [__] van halen and
go on the road with sammy hagar i mean
what can you do right now
for me i'm pretty content what i had i
mean i'd like to start a business if i
could or something like that i'm not
saying i'm dead
but my life is not about me anymore it's
about those [__] kids and bringing a
smile to their face you know when i was
a kid man
my mother was involved in a ton of [__]
and you know we had the bar and the
numbers and all this
weirdness going around but one thing
about my mother was
she always went out of her [__] way
for me to have a good summer
i really gotta tell you guys that she
went
out of her [__] way and i
thank her for that i i thank her for
teaching me that quality
her summers were about the kids
period
everything in her world slowed down a
little bit her
her [__] drinking her [__] working
at the bar and she paid attention to
kids i'm being in the sixth grade in
north bergen
and it'd be in the summer going into
seventh grade
and me and my buddies would go up to the
bar and she would [__]
put like a fountain outside for us like
a puerto rican hula hoop like you know
all these little activities there were
nothing it was like a hose with a can to
give it like a [__] effect and she
would set up balls for us to throw
wiffle ball and put a target on the wall
just so we could have things but not
only that she always made sure i had a
[__] vacation
like she always made sure like where you
going this year i don't we start talking
about it like in [__] april like for
that vacation she'd go what are you
thinking of doing this summer and i
would either pick california with my
uncle i would pick nine out of ten i'd
pick miami with my cousins but one thing
i remember and i told my daughter i go
listen man we're gonna start coming down
here a little more
because my fondest memories of a child
they're going to [__] miami beach
and us being like a mediocre hotel you
know like i don't know because it was a
lot of us it was me my three cousins
other cousins other friends it was like
30 of us in a hotel so instead of
getting like a castaways and getting a
whole floor they would get a little
lower hotel i forget what the name of it
was it was like the castaways the
newport i stayed at all those hotels in
miami beach except one
uh at one time or another when we went
on vacation but as i got older we would
always stay at this certain hotel and my
fondest [__] memory i remember just
walking to the newport i don't know if
you guys are familiar with miami beach
not south beach miami beach i'm too old
for [__] south beach i grew up on
miami beach
and i would walk to the end of the pool
me and my cousins would be like nine of
us and our job starting at ten o'clock
was to jump in all the pools at the
hotel and get chased
this might not sound
like fun to you [__] but when
you're eight and nine
it's a lot of [__] fun you know it's
a lot of fun
to [__] just swim all day so we'd
jump in the pool
and go to that one until a lifeguard
would throw us out and then we go into
another one the one right next door and
then they throw us out then we jump in
the beach and come up into the other
hotel through the cones because they'd
put cones to separate the hotels and we
would jump into that pool and we'd get
in like six pools by lunchtime then we'd
run all the way home
eat lunch and then run back to the pool
we [__] and then we'd go to the
castaways and they had seven pools so
your goal was only at the castaways they
had seven [__] pools all right that's
how big that hotel was so our job just
wasn't to jump into one [__] pool our
job was to jump into all seven [__]
pools at the castaway and they would
catch us by like the fifth pool so we
would have to do it again the next day
and the [__] what the [__] i
just drew you guys out yesterday we
don't give a [__] we're coming back
today i mean we would cause havoc down
there miami beaches and then we'd end up
at our hotel and my uncle rodolfo god
bless his soul this is the clinker you
ready
we would be with him for two weeks and
then he would disappear for like five
days to do business but when he come
back that third week on thursday like he
we wouldn't see him from like
maybe monday to thursday when we'd see
him on thursday he would [__] pull up
to the beach with the boat
and we would have to swim out to him and
he would pull us on the boat and then
we'd go out fishing and we catch fish
and i still remember fishing with them
and getting seasick and like puking
everywhere as a kid and all the kids
were making fun of me look pukey i'm
puking and i never forget like i just
put my head up for something and rodolfo
goes how about a piece of fish i'm like
what the [__] like that's my best
memories of growing up so i'm like i
told mercy of this because why are we
going down the show i go because
this is what we do like i even forgot
about it i forgot guys my head has been
so far up my ass for the last 30 years
i've been
so busy with whatever the [__] was in
front of me that i never even thought of
my life i never i didn't even remember
these stories about miami as a kid going
down there listening to the [__]
eagles for the first time like oh yeah
and like sniffing a beer and like
getting all [__] up like just from
sniffing a beer like
that's what it is to be a [__] kid
man
you know and i see
and i know the world is a different
place the united states you know
there's people that
aren't doing that well right now that
can't go down there like i mean i
couldn't afford the [__] show every
week
it would bust you they ain't [__]
around down there guys you know they're
charging six seven eight hundred dollars
a night for a [__] hotel that's a lot
of [__] money guys but you know
you're chipping with your friends and
you could still make a day out of it you
know we all [__] put in money and we
all made the [__] best of what we can
you know but when it comes to the
summers and [__]
it's about your kids it's not about me
no i don't even have a life anymore you
know i do some stand-up i have a good
time you know i'll tell you
i had a great [__] time last week if
you guys came to any of the shows
you know man i don't know it took a
while for me to get going and i'm happy
it did i'm happy i didn't push it out
there like i told you guys i could have
just gone on the road charged you 30
bucks and gone up there and didn't give
a [__] i didn't want to do that i really
wanted to start over from scratch and
have a good time doing it
this week i had a [__] great time if
you came to uncle vinnie's wednesday it
was great and the stress factory man
that's a great club and i love that club
i'm gonna put another date together for
august but i'll tell you why i love that
club stressful i love both those clubs i
wouldn't be doing them as much as i do
i love distress factory because it's a
great date night
they got great [__] restaurants in
the area you could go to cousins
you go to state uh 85 you go to salt you
go to the stage i mean if you're going
with a date or something
one of my friends went he called me back
when i left he goes dog i went i found a
spanish restaurant i didn't even know
there were spanish people in new
brunswick never mind a spanish
restaurant
so it's just a great place and uncle
vinnie's is great because you're down
the [__] shore right there you leave
there at 9 30 you're a half hour with
the seaside you're down there you can
just stay in point pleasant go to
jerkins jenkinson's got a [__]
cocktail they got tons of [__] i love
all that [__] you know i still haven't
gone into the city yet i've gotten my
[__] uh i just got my dates
five dates for the
[Music]
for new york city
so uh i'll bust those out to you in a
couple [__] days to get you guys
ready to go
the first show at the sony theater
starts september 17th
and uh i'm excited man but this week
like all i'm doing with stand up right
now
i'm taking this is what i forced myself
to do first off i want to thank you guys
for holding me to thursday nights i
think i completed
eight thursdays in a row
we had none for a while so now we have
eight in a row this week hopefully i'll
make it nine every thursday i gotta go
out and find the [__] spot that's the
deal we made so that's been working
but i thought about something i went up
on stage the other night with just one
[__] joke i was gonna i looked at 40
minutes
in the weirdest way the other day i just
looked at it with one joke i just came
out and said
let's get this out of the way
what about the transgender guy they put
in the jail
and he ended up [__] two chicks and
knocked them up
and i think everybody knew what the [__]
i was talking about because everybody
just looked at me like what the [__] and
if you guys don't know the story i guess
last week somewhere in jersey they
discovered that uh there was a
transgender dude
who they put him in the women's jail
because he said he was a woman
but he forgot to [__] disclose that
he still had a 10 inch [__] and he
impregnated two [__] girls in there
so now they put him on the juvenile
whatever and it was just funny because
everybody always says you know again
i appreciate what's going on in life now
things are changing but i think the
change is a little
has been a little too quick and i think
uh that we're getting ahead of ourselves
as americans and everybody's making a
big splash about something
you know uh a patreon guy hit me up and
he goes joy i went to uncle vinnie's i
didn't you know i kind of got upset not
really with the
trans material and i'm like listen if
you listen to my whole set
i didn't pull a dave chappelle i just
went up there
and talked about this situation
this particular situation
and then after all my transgender jokes
if i do them
this week i also tell the story of
the kid that my
my daughter was friends with that his
parents had done the
his mother had went from being a man
to a woman and then they invited me to a
birthday party
and i was a little upset i was like i'm
not going to that [__] party and [__]
they might shoot me with esterol or
something like that estrogen or some
[__]
but then when i went to the party i
realized that
he was an adopted kid and whatever these
people are they gave this kid a [__]
home and
if i'm the real deal holyfield i should
be happy for them
adopting him and that's what happened
i saw all these adopted little kids
because they had like a transgender
community
i saw all these adopted little kids and
the smile on their faces and what
difference does it make who adopted them
whether they're transgender martians
whatever the [__] they are
they saved a little boy's life so i
looked at it from that way and i ended
up becoming friends with those parents
they were great [__] people i mean
the last 18 months i was in la i was i
would see them and speak to them and
they would hug me and we talked i loved
the little boy marvin that was his name
[__] marvin cutest little boy you
ever seen in your life looked like
[__] steve mcqueen blonde ham
beautiful [__] blue eyes but
so i tell that story and then people
lighten up a little bit but i didn't say
it in a bad way i'm not looking to be
dave chappelle by no way by no means i
just thought you know comedy is how my
world crashes with the rest of the world
and i think that my joke was well wait a
second
you know these people like when i bumped
into the transgender mom who said well
she wasn't a transgender
but she was like a cheerleader whatever
for
and she was telling me how she wanted to
you know her son always wanted to be a
woman you know and i can understand that
but what happened at this jail was this
guy decided one day
he wanted to be a woman and what ended
up happening he ended up
[__] two chicks so he forgot
you know i also thought that when you
claimed transgender you had already cut
your dick off
so i did not know this not maybe i'm not
knowledgeable enough maybe i'm a little
ignorant
of what's going on here but it i still
feel the same no matter [__] what
what if uh that's your daughter in the
bathroom
and he comes into a woman's bathroom
remember that was a big issue for a
while
same there you go that's my vote right
there no
no and i'm being honest with you guys no
no no no
because everybody said that that would
happen okay that might be once in a
million he might be a rotten apple you
know what i'm saying but just because of
that case
i'm not gonna [__] uh i'm not gonna
approve that [__] you cannot i don't
mind you going to that bathroom but you
got to cut your dick off and i'm not
saying this in a funny [__] way you
got to go straight through the [__]
surgery you can't tell me that you feel
like a woman no no no no no no i don't
want to hear that [__] you either all
percent in and then you go into the
women's bathroom or the woman's
correction and they took the guy
after he whatever [__] the two chicks
and knocked him up and they put him in
the juvenile detection detention place
again how the [__] do you feel he's got
a 30-year sentence
for murder he ain't going nowhere
so he could keep now the reason why he's
transgender because he knows in general
pop they'll stab him both side of his
necks
they don't play that [__] in general pop
you know and if they do he's got a suck
dick or whatever i don't know how it
works when i was in jail there was a
couple [__] in there like nut [__] but
those people who put wigs on and
highline and a dress and they get beat
up i don't know i used to just be nice
to the guys and give them extra food on
the line but they get beat up it's just
the life of [__] horror in jail when
you go in there with a wig and eyeliner
and [__] either either you're [__]
all in
you know it's just a [__]
crazy world we're living in now and uh
you know
they [__] canceled chappelle at uh
that club in minneapolis where prince
shot his uh
his uh purple rain videos or the special
he did i don't know
and people are upset about that but
listen man
this is going to be the new norm
i mean i'm not going to say the names of
the clubs but there's a couple clubs
that are already working woke
i can't go in there i got no work
material i don't want to be woke i don't
want to be in that [__] situation you
know
it's so funny how i see this woke thing
i don't know
guys when i
i've been in jersey now for two years
and i've seen that
i went down to tuckerton this weekend
and while we were there
i was talking to my friend and the
neighbor lady
is a very granolish lady
she's what we call a gentile
and it was funny that she was talking
about the woman next door not in a
negative way but she was saying all her
like her little [__] faults like you
know she does this she overreacts and
i'm like she's a gentile you know that's
what you call a gentile
in new jersey you know and it's like
when i left new jersey there was very
few gentiles here
they were all rough necks the gentiles
were in the village you know that's
where you got all that amazing and all
that you know that's where yokohono was
great
you know listen you're not a fan of yoko
ono you'll never be a fan of yokono i
know one of our performances rattled you
but yokono's got no fans nobody ever
said i love yoko only music but when i
was growing up these gentiles in the
village
they loved yoko won you know like they
would tell you right now you don't know
what you're talking about yoko ono's
brilliant okay you know because they
have that little
yeah like that little [__] [__]
community of
last night i was watching 60 minutes
and they were interviewing this chick
that's into sounds and noises did you
watch 60 minutes about i don't know what
her name is in fact she had a hit in
1980 on mtv
and it's just a chick that does you know
electronic noises and [__] well
she ended up being married to lou reed
she married lou reed before she married
them for like 20 years you know and they
showed
lou reed music like lou reed performing
oh god that is [__] bad
that is really bad i know there's a lot
of little reef fans out there i don't
mean to insult you but i'm just trying
to make a point here like lou reed lou
reed was music for certain people if you
like that [__] i didn't like that [__]
there's certain music that i sit there
and i go there's no way anybody likes
this music
they like this music to be different
to be away from the regular people like
they don't want to be
somewhere at a party
they somebody said at a party somebody
goes we don't listen to led zeppelin we
don't listen to commun communized music
and these guys run with it trust me what
i'm telling you how it works and now
it's like constant you know we don't
listen to that we listen to
you know yoko ono and lou reed well
[__] lou reed was [__] terrible
you know
and this is what i'm saying to you
people there's this and now those people
who like lou reed they're all over new
york like those people who would have
liked new read they're all over [__]
new york when i went to that movie
theater
with ari i saw [__] creatures in the
night in there with tight shorts and
they're trying to [__] be somebody
and you know what guys listen when i was
a young man i was confused i had my
little shortcomings and all this [__]
but there's people that you see
that are constantly
they're so different
that they feel it they feel insecure i
mean if you don't think i felt insecure
i feel i feel insecure all the [__]
time i have i am the most insecure
[__] person out there i feel insecure
around intelligent people i feel
insecure again about a ton of situation
that you put me in
but that doesn't mean that i'm gonna be
something i'm not
like i went to the [__] philly game
and i'm sitting there and i see this
girl walk by with blue hair the whole
[__] the whole i need attention
package that's what i call it it's the i
need attention package
and when you don't get attention doing
that then you push the extreme
you go i didn't get attention doing that
i'm gonna do this and get more attention
and you see these people whatever the
[__] they do with the 22 earrings and
their eyeballs whatever the [__] they do
and you look at them they go hey
different folks with different folks
that's not me but
i feel sometimes those people [__]
just yelling for [__] attention
and if they don't get it they'll keep
pushing push and push and pushing more
you know it's really a mental health
issue at times
i yes i do believe
that there are people that wake up every
morning and go man i feel like a woman
i want to give birth i want to do and
trust me i've had this conversation with
a few people that's how i learned about
this but i think now and it's like what
bill maher said a couple weeks ago it's
like the hip thing to do
like i didn't get you with this i didn't
get you with that i'm gonna become
transgender
okay i understand where you're coming
from but do me a [__] favor
do the full operation
you can't go around telling people
you're a woman and if you got a dick and
then you're gonna switch back
you can't do that it's like me saying
i'm this and then i switch back you guys
are going to get sick and that's what i
get sick of but i've always felt
that like when i was a kid it was always
i don't know they wanted to do different
things to feel different
and i get it i know what it is to feel
insecure or whatever but i'm not gonna
do something or be something i'm not
just to get that that's why i tell
people all the time don't use people
don't use people you know don't ever use
anybody i did one time and it stayed
with me forever and i hated myself
forever i didn't know i wasn't in love
with this person
and we got put together and i didn't
[__] uh then you we could always say
you can always say you know what i don't
love this person but in time i'll get to
love this person no you don't
no you don't i love you very early on i
[__] don't love you i'm not gonna get
to love you more in [__] time yeah i
love my wife more i've been with her for
20 years but my initial love for her
was for her and then over the [__] 20
years yeah it got harder we went through
different things but love is love and
it's so weird how i see these people
and it's
listen if they were confused people
before the [__]
pandemic what do you think is going on
now
i mean you want to see mental health
issues just pop up instagram on any
[__] day
you know the great rudy sarzo once told
me that music entertainment
film all that [__] there's a thin line
between uh
that and mental illness
and i knew it hey i'm not the [__]
most sharpest guy in the world either
you know what i'm saying
but
there's a big disconnect and now after
the pandemic i'm seeing it
i'm seeing millionaires acting [__]
desperate you know so
i don't know where i'm getting that i
just wanted to talk to you guys it's a
beautiful [__] monday you guys are
gonna get this on a tuesday but
i don't know after that situation
that i wanted to bring that to the stage
because i wanted to get a joke out of it
but it's really not a joke if you really
think about it
and i tried to turn it into a joke and
that's what we do that's what comedy is
and my world collides with everything
and i gotta give it color you know when
you get married there's nothing funny
about getting married even tell somebody
i'm getting married then i'm going
no but describe your wedding to
describe your particular wedding to him
i was talking to my nephew you got
married in june 7th or something june
13th i don't know what the [__] the date
is
the hall he had
had a pond in the back
you know three people fell in that pond
during the wedding including the [__]
photographer
the photographer was taking pictures and
he kept walking back and he just
fell into the [__] wedding you follow
me when he told me the story he added
that color and he broke he's a funny guy
my nephew and i was [__] dying on the
phone if anybody else would i could have
said hey he just three people found the
thing like i told you i wasn't there so
i can't describe the fall his father
fell in the water the photographer and
one of the one of his uh wife's uncles
or something fell on the [__] thing i
don't even know how he got to this
but uh no it was it was surreal
i don't like what's going on and listen
guys i'm not gonna jump on the bandwagon
about that type of material but
those type of jokes i have to look and
have to address
that's my [__] world it's not that i
don't hate anybody i'm too old listen
guys i don't give a [__] anymore
are you guys not listening to me that i
don't i am in the best position for
stand-up in about a year you guys are
going to read something on twitter on
instagram how i got thrown out of a club
but that's the end of my career i don't
i could care less after that
because i have nothing to fight for i'm
just trying to be funny i'm just working
to be the funniest [__] out
there i don't care about netflix
specials i don't give a [__] if you put
me in your festival i don't give a [__]
if i go to montreal i don't give a [__]
if i'm the comic of the year all that's
[__]
i just want to be funny and that's why
we started getting into this so if you
got insulted at the shows at the stretch
factory or whatever i know nobody got
insulted because nobody gets insulted at
my [__] shows i don't allow it i
don't give a [__]
you're not gonna this is jersey [__]
okay if you're easily to offend then go
mend a sweater go to a [__]
go to a [__] uh
what do you call those people go to
watch a snoopy movie but i i i don't go
out to offend people i'm just trying to
be funny
and to have a good [__] time i got no
dates for you [__] all i got is
september 17th
at the [__] sony theater in new
york city i'm gonna approve the dates
tonight and uh get them out to you guys
and that's it and that's that brother
i'm having a great time i'm sorry i'm
late with the podcast this week
wednesday we got a guest thursday we'll
get it why not i don't want to release
it
wednesday morning so you got today
tuesday and you got thursday then we're
back on schedule next [__] week thank
you for watching uncle joey's joint and
don't forget we got a big [__] ufc
card this weekend so stay black
[__] i love you have a great week
and i'll see you guys thursday dip top
lagoon liquid iv all right i want to
thank you guys
for listening do not forget
ufc 277
and draftkings the official
sports betting partner ufc listen they
got a tremendous offer this week this
saturday new customers your best five
dollars on any fighter to win and i'm
gonna get you 103 bets
win or lose you want to have tremendous
action you could do a same game paulie
the more legs you add the more money you
win so let's say you like amanda nunes
the over and maybe she's gonna get it
with a [__] submission boom there you
go three bets you just made some money
that's why i love [__] draftkings
because for ufc 277 the same game paulie
is in full [__] effect if it hits you
win double draft kings is safe secure
and reliable you got derek lewis you got
moreno you got amanda nunes juliana pena
let's get some [__] cash download the
draftkings workbook app right now
use promo code joey and if you bet 5 000
then the ufc 277 fighter win
you get 103 bets no matter what who's
better than you nobody that's called
joey this saturday a draftking sports
book the official sports betting partner
of the ufc
minimum age
and eligibility requirements apply you
understand me
if someone you know has a gambling
problem
call 1-800-426-2537
if you're in arizona 1-800 next step
but
if you're in tennessee 1-800-889-9789
[Music]
listen to me just get help
the joint is also brought to you by
better help
when it comes to therapy better help is
there for you listen we spend a lot of
time on taking care of all parts of our
lives but we never really look into our
mind
it's time with better help why better
help better help
offers online therapy accessible
convenient and affordable it's either
video phone or chat therapy sessions you
can choose not to even see anybody if
you don't want to i started working with
better health about two years ago with
dana
and here i am today tip
top magoo you meet with them once a week
or twice a week and you talk it out they
have exercises for you and that's what
betterhelp.com does so do me a favor the
joint listeners get 10 percent off your
first month with betterhelp.com
diaz again that's betterhelp.com
diaz take care of yourselves with better
help the joint is also brought to you by
boom
cbd line when it gets the cbd
there's nobody better than cbd line how
do i know because i live cbd lion do
yourselves a favor read the third party
lab results
and go get some cbd to help you out
whether you have a bad elbow you can't
sleep anxiety listen that cbd line
tincture is tremendous and
the [__] delta eight gummies will
help will make you or help you hear
chinese music so do me a favor
go to cbd lion
pick something you like press and code
joey church or joint and get 20 off i
want to thank better help i want to
thank cbd lion and i also want to thank
draftkings but most importantly you
[__] savages for having my back i'll
see you thursday morning tip
top magoo stay black